let's go next to our caller from the 6-5
zero area code who's calling today from
six five zero
yes hello that me yes it is yes this is
a will I'm calling from Washington DC I
was mostly calling to talk a little bit
about the alternatives or to the sort of
policing systems and we have we're
talking about defunding the police right
and it doing so do you believe that that
would maybe create a lot more informal
conflict resolution that would occur
like naturally in communities sort of
R'lyeh than that because I know that in
more developing countries they sort of
run into this problem where you know
crimes are committed constantly but
people don't have old many criminal
histories officially because the police
just aren't involved in a lot of
criminal aspects things like that right
and how that works and in terms of doing
so that gives like a lot of employers
and a little bit of you Tommy a lot of
confidence who they hire they can trust
things like that it's tended to be a big
a social fabric and I just want to see
you to speak about that yeah an informal
conflict resolution can be good or bad
depending on the context right you do
have places where things like burglaries
or or physical crimes are dealt with by
families or groups or mob like entities
essentially dealing with it by
themselves and I don't know that that's
really any better than having police
involvement in other cases for other
types of disputes you can certainly
support infrastructure for resolution
that doesn't involve police but what is
important to understand is a lot of
these conflicts I guess is the word
we're using a lot of these conflicts
aren't really resolved by police in the
sense that police may be involved
initially but really it's the court
system that ultimately is adjudicating
right either through plea deals state's
attorneys and prosecutors etc so I think
it's also important when we think about
you know defund versus reform and you
know we've already I've already had that
conversation
a bunch of times this week we also want
to not pretend that the police are more
involved in the resolution of a lot of
these things now because really the
police you know in a burglary police are
showing up and they're eventually it's
assigned to a detective and an
investigation is done but eventually
really the resolution and the
disposition is determined by the court
system and that's a different system
it's part of a broader law enforcement
apparatus in a sense but it's a
different system so I think it's
important we don't want to overstate or
understate where police are and are not
involved if that makes sense no question
okay all right appreciate the call thank
you so much let's go next to our caller
from the 9:08 area code who's calling
today from 9:08
hi is this me yes it is who's this Oh
my name is furry huh I'm from New Jersey
so it's like such a pleasure to be able
to talk to you I really love your shop
and like a year now Wow thank you the
pleasure is mine yeah um I guess like I
had a very general broad question for
you sure and I wanted to know what sorry
I just want to know what we're the
biggest inspiration for like your
progressive out look like regarding
social and economic policies I have no
idea how to quantify that I mean you
know map my views today are built on
essentially twenty years of following
politics and reading economics history
philosophy I I really couldn't say my
biggest inspirations I mean you know
that it's built on reading everything
from you know Oh 18th century philosophy
and ancient Greek philosophy to Angus
Deaton book on economic well-being
written a few years ago you know it's
really really tough and I wouldn't I at
this point it's hard to say any one or
another inspiration I mean I think the
frame
I'm operating under overall is I would
be what I consider a left libertarian
social democrat in that i want a
compelling reason to have government
involved in endeavours and there are
compelling reasons to have government
involved in health care and education
not so much in manufacturing airplanes
but the regulatory responsibilities of
government is huge there i want people
to have as much freedom for
self-determination as possible and
government should be very involved in
setting those conditions but not going
beyond that in terms of determining what
jobs people should have or the the like
i mean it's it's a it's an interesting
question because it goes to my general
framework and at this point i've been
following all this stuff for so long for
you how that it's like that i couldn't
name like three people that have mostly
inspired me if that makes sense okay
yeah I was just wondering because um I
actually majored in economics and
marketing in my undergraduate studies
man I I always feel like this kind of
loan like progressive voice or like
having this like progressive outlook I
guess amongst my peers and so it's like
I guess I'm more interested in learning
more about like economic policy whether
like whether it be progressive or more
conservative to like I guess about get a
better feel for to get a better feel for
my understanding of how I actually want
the government to function and yeah I
mean I think the problem with a lot of
economics departments in the u.s. is
that they teach a really narrow range of
stuff I mean I've said before I have no
problem with neoclassical economics
being taught and it's important to
understand that framework but when I
went to undergraduate University of
Massachusetts
you know I write socialist Richard Wolff
was one of my professors and I you know
learned Marxian economics and game
theory and I got into behavioral
economics personally after I graduated
and it's most economics programs are
teaching far too narrow a scope of
material and it sounds like that's sort
of what you're realizing
yeah it's like it's like a huge issue
like I took environmental economics
looking up for local economic selective
actually went erectors University and I
noticed that a lot of the framework was
dealing with neoclassical theory and how
I was just wondering how a little bit
limited it is dealing with negative
externalities arising from like things
like pollution or like some things not
being responsible for like we've managed
and are things like a bad nature yeah I
mean neoclassical economics and market
theory fails to deal with a Pro fails to
appropriately deal with externalities
I'm actually reading it none of the
concepts are new but it's an interesting
book I'm reading naked economics by
Whelan is his last name I believe he
teaches at Dartmouth I forget his first
name and it has an entire chapter
devoted to how you need government
involved in markets because without it
the negative externalities are dealt
with only in that they are passed along
to somebody else and your your analysis
is exactly right all right I guess
somebody might only questions thank you
so much for taking my call you're like a
huge inspiration for me because you
ain't you really kind of steal man my
progressive politics and Gotham
realities I can defend them a little bit
easier so I truly appreciate your voice
there please then have a good day okay
you too I so appreciate the phone call
thank you